as a young girl knowing that she would
one day be head of the Armed Forces
Elizabeth asked her father if she could
join the territorial auxiliary service
which is a faction of the army and so
she worked as a mechanic
um during those War years you know she
would take an engine apart and I think
it goes some way to understanding why
she was always so brilliant behind the
wheel of a Land Rover and wasn't afraid
to go off terrain because if that car
broke down real chance than not she'd
know how to fix it I think knowing that
she was a future Queen knowing that she
was going to be head of the Armed Forces
for Elizabeth at least it was very
important that she had some
understanding of what it was like to be
in the Army so the Tas the territory
auxiliary service provided a really good
training ground and I also think it was
a really good leveler for her you know
she was there working as a mechanic with
ordinary people and so I think she
earned the respect of the people and it
was a very valuable lesson for her too I
think the reason that her children went
in and had careers some short-lived
others like Prince Harry 10 years long
and serving two tours of Afghanistan was
actually so that they could serve their
grandmother the queen as head of the
armed services and if you look at the
Royal Family the Queen's father was a
naval officer and the King was also in
the Army so that affiliation with the
military goes right back and and
something that you know the queen
obviously wanted to be able to
experience and she did that by joining
that faction of the army